and through loud and clear you know
we're doing this live and live means
that there are all sorts of things that
can go wrong so hopefully you're hearing
me and seeing me and I'm gonna assume
that that is the case and those of you
who are new to this little series that
we've been running it's called your
daily equation and you know the point of
it is look we're all dealing with this
difficult tragic situation right now in
the world and we have to pay close
attention to all of the difficult
painful details but it's nice to be able
to pull away from those details every
day for just a little bit some people
will get a sort of mental relief through
comedy some through music I don't know
how many of you have seen this wonderful
version of the opening song to Hamilton
that the original cast did on YouTube
which is really just quite wonderful
that that for me is a great mental break
but what we do here is not does not use
music or comedy per se but rather
equations things that tap into the deep
truths of reality to give us a ability
to kind of step away from the
difficulties of the moment and connect
with something that transcends ourselves
so that's what this is all about and
this is the live session in which I'm
here to answer any and every one of the
questions that I can get to in the
limited time we have and it's great to
begin by just sort of having people
weigh in and let us know where you're
from I think some people in the chat
already began to do that but I kind of
love to see the different countries
scroll by I saw Copenhagen I saw Germany
India others so you know we're kind of
this little global community of people
who care about these kind of esoteric
ideas that really tap into some of the
most important ideas that we have ever
developed as a species all right so we
assume Canada Belgium Ontario Romania
Morocco Chicago Staten Island Holland UK
India Poland India great fantastic all
right so let's actually jump right in to
the first question that
I have here which is from Jones Philip
or Philip Jones don't know the right
orientation of the name what do you
think will happen after we find a
unified field theory will a new arena
come up or will it be the end of
theoretical physics and yeah I mean
that's a that's an important question to
ask there are those who may recall that
Albert Einstein had this dream of
finding what he called the unified
theory and a unified theory was meant to
in essence be a master principle a
master idea that might be articulated in
a single master equation that would be
able to describe everything in the
physical universe and so the natural
question that Jones Philip or Philip
Jones is asking is well if you have that
is that the end of physics you sort of
have the final answer and I would say it
would be the end of one particular
chapter in physics in that chapter is
the chapter in which for a very long
time we have been searching for the
fundamental ingredients and the
fundamental laws that govern those
ingredients and if we had this unified
theory it might be the final chapter in
that long story right the reductionist
account of the universe might be on full
display if we had the unified theory but
would that be the end of science
certainly not right reductionist
accounts giving you the fundamental laws
and the fundamental ingredients need
then to feed into a synthetic account a
synthesis of the ingredients so that we
understand how they come together into
all manner of structure in the world
right how do they come together into for
instance living systems you don't fully
know the answer to that yet how do those
ingredients come together into conscious
beings how do they yield the ability to
reflect and feel and sense things about
the world
how do those ingredients come together
and yield the fabric of space-time how
do they interface in the most complete
manner with extreme objects in the
universe like black holes so these kinds
of questions will carry on for a very
long
time and the one thing to bear in mind
is the history of science teaches us
that every time you gain a new insight
it allows you to ask questions that you
couldn't even imagine asking you
couldn't even think of the questions
until you had the advances necessary to
formulate those questions so I see this
as an ongoing process that will just
continue this trail of discovery for as
long as we conjugating beings are here
to think and to care about it alright
daniela daniela Herbert how would you
describe the fundamental differences
between physicists and engineers
specifically mechanical engineers and
how can we improve collaboration between
our two fields yeah so physicists and
I'm gonna speak as a theoretical
physicist so I can make this more
personal we're dealing in a world
largely of equations and mathematics and
trying to create and develop equations
that are ever more adept at describing
things that we see in the world and
we've done a really good job right we
understand many of the fundamental
particles I understand electricity
magnetism and all manner of forces that
are at work
guiding how these particles come
together Engineers tend to focus more on
using the insights of science to make
things to to build things and if I'm
gonna be completely honest I certainly
have what might be called EE engineering
Envy right I mean I I envy people who
understand the science so well that they
can put it into practice and and create
things I kind of wish that I could do
that I can't or at least I've never
really tried I always thought I never
had the ability to do anything but the
ax man thematics in the equations but
there's a depth of understanding that
you have to have to be an engineer
because it's not a matter of just making
it work on paper it's got to work out
there in the real world so I think there
are many opportunities for the two
fields to work
together if an engineer is stumped on
some theoretical calculation perhaps
gaining the assistance of a theoretical
physicist would help push that program
forward and on occasion physicists like
me do want to see the ideas were
developing put into practice in fact you
may not know this and I think this is
not apocryphal so I hope I'm not
spreading some like silly internet rumor
I believe I've got this knowledge from a
reputable source yeah I believe it's
true I'm pretty sure that Albert
Einstein yeah I'm quite sure about this
Albert Einstein had a patent for a
certain kind of refrigeration system
right so here's the guy who's thinking
about quantum mechanics and general
relativity and special relativity and
all the beautiful equations of 20th
century physics and he was able to cross
the divide and think about real things
in the real world so the fields don't
need to be separate and when they come
together I think it's a potent way to
put powerful theoretical ideas into
real-world practice so good question
Martha Guadalupe del consuelo asks
besides string theory what other theory
do you like most to explain similar
things that string theory is trying to
answer yeah I mean right so string
theory is a theory that I work on it's
meant to try to be the unified theory
that Einstein is looking for but we
don't know if string theory is right it
could be that it's the final unified
theory it could also be a figment of
string theorists imagination
mathematical imagination that's kind of
a chimera that doesn't actually have any
substance it doesn't have any ability to
really describe things in the real world
am i work on paper but it might not work
in practice it's sort of a version of
the engineering question right so it
could be a theoretical idea of no real
consequence to understanding how the
world works I hope that's not the case
I'd like to think that what we're
developing in string theory really does
have some impact on our understanding of
the real world but we don't know yet so
what are the competitors right in the
situation like that you hope that there
are competitors
and there are other theories loop
quantum gravity is probably the most
developed other approach to putting
gravity and quantum into quantum
mechanics together that would be kind of
a beautiful answer to how these distinct
approaches fit together you might say
well you're just you know thinking in
two
grandiose away it's not as though
ultimately string theorists and loop
quantum gravity folks are gonna all hold
hands around the campfire and hum the
unified theory right that may just be a
pipe dream but on the other hand you
know each theory has its own successes
and maybe in combination they'll be able
to do what the individual theories on
their own are unable to so I don't think
it's a ridiculous outcome to imagine but
certainly we're far from it today
Neelam asks is it possible that dark
energy might exist in higher dimension
interviews talk about time travel being
a real quality of physical law my
question is are you being hyperbolic or
is time travel actually possible that's
a good question and maybe I should
quickly say that I really truly try not
to be hyperbolic in interviews you know
I naturally get excited about ideas that
I feel passionate about but it's very
rare I mean I'm sure somebody can dig up
some interview where I will violate what
I'm about to say but it's very rare that
I say something that I regret or that I
say something that when I reflect back
on I'm like whoa I kind of went on a
tackle equation your daily equation
after all why not so let's see if I
could bring up some good so hey hi there
you go so you know you can be
quantitative about this and if you take
your velocity V to be let me just sort
of pick a good number a number that's
really close to the speed of ice so take
point nine nine nine nine nine nine so
six nines right there let's go to nine
nines and then like that times
but really close to the speed of light
if you then calculate this factor called
gamma which is one over the square root
of one minus V over C squared you just
put this into a calculator I'm not gonna
do the arithmetic for you but this is on
the order of a factor of roughly 200
thousands an example that physicists
like to use I hope I've got the right
nines in there but feel free to correct
me if when you plug it into a calculator
you get a different answer but I think
that's correct and what this means is
that when you step off the ship after
that one year round-trip journey it will
be 200,000 years into Earth's future you
will not see earth in the year 2020 2021
you will see it in the year 200,000 and
2021 all right so 200,000 years later
and that is not something that's
disputed right this is our understanding
of how physics works as given to us by
Albert Einstein so yeah that's a real
kind of time travel time travel to the
future again travel to the past I don't
have much to say about it there have
been proposals but it's not something
that anybody I think really puts much
stock in today and I appreciate that
question because I think I could be
wrong but at least in America I think
this is national sibling day I think
something like that so the little
scenario I just told you you can imagine
two twins are on planet Earth and one
twin goes off into space and undertakes
that journey and comes back and that
twin will be very young compared to the
twin that stayed on earth the example I
described the twin on earth with age
200,000 years during that one year
travel time okay good question
all right what do we have here seung-jo
prasad what was before the Big Bang yeah
it's a it's a it's a question I'm
frequently asked and one possible answer
is there was nothing before the Big Bang
in the sense that the whole concept of
before assumes that there's a
kind of time a notion of time that's
relevant before the Big Bang happened
but it could be that time itself begins
at the Big Bang and therefore their
notion of before doesn't have any
meaning there another possibility is
that the Big Bang may not have been the
beginning of time it may have been the
beginning of the realm that we inhabit
in a larger space-time but there could
have been events that happened before
the Big Bang in fact in inflationary
cosmology the suggestion is that our
universe our Big Bang may be one among a
collection may be an infinite collection
of Big Bang's each giving rise to their
own separate expanding realm in which
case our Big Bang is just one event and
there are other bangs other universes
and that might be another answer to the
question of what happened before other
big bangs okay Marc asks why aren't we
impacted by the expansion of the
universe if the space between galaxies
are increasing space between galaxies is
increasing why isn't the space between
molecules or atoms increasing good good
good and there's a very straightforward
answer to that question which is this so
our bodies and molecules and atoms are
held together by largely by the
electromagnetic force the nuclei of
atoms held together by the strong
nuclear force let's focus just on the
electromagnetic force for now the
electromagnetic force is far more
powerful than the force of gravity how
do you know that well you know look at
this I can pick up my my Apple pencil
whatever it's called right the entire
Earth is pulling on this Apple pencil
and yet my puny little arms which are
moving under the electromagnetic force
that is governing how my muscles
contract and so forth my puny muscles
overcome the entire gravitational pull
of a planet of the earth and that shows
you that the intrinsic strength of
gravity is very small compared
intrinsic strength of the
electromagnetic force which means as
space expands which is ultimately a
gravitational process the
electromagnetic force holding together
molecules and atoms and human bodies is
far more powerful than that outward
spreading and that's why we hold
together now it's not necessarily the
case that this will always hold true
there are versions of cosmology in which
the expansion of space is not only
speeding up accelerating as it is today
their versions of cosmology in which the
acceleration accelerates the outward
push that's driving everything apart it
gets stronger over time and if that's
the case then it's possible that in the
future the our push will be stronger
than the electromagnetic force that
holds things together in which case
planets may ultimately blast apart
human bodies may blast apart even
molecules and atoms may get ripped apart
it's called the big rip scenario and so
we don't know if this is the case
measurements are currently underway to
to figure out if the so-called dark
energy which we believe is pushing
everything apart gravitationally to
determine whether the dark energy is
granting strength over time if it is
this is the fate that might await us in
the future so right now no worry that
the expansion of space is going to blow
us apart in the future that may not be
the case okay let's see what we got here
Andrea Andrea climbing says would the
probabilistic nature of quantum
mechanics argue against a deterministic
universe and in favor of free well and
yeah I mean it's a it's a natural
thought to have because in the Newtonian
universe where we learn back in school
right that you tell me the positions and
the velocities of the objects the
ingredients the particle
and you plug in the forces that are
acting upon them and you use Newton's F
equals MA to figure out how those
ingredients will move over time and that
way you can't predict with certainty how
the universe will be configured tomorrow
based on how its configured today so
with such rigidity in the unfolding of
the universe there appears to be no room
for free will so some people come along
and say well that's true in a classical
Newtonian world but come on we don't
live in that world we live in a quantum
mechanical world in which the
progression from today until tomorrow is
governed by different considerations
governed by the considerations of
probability right the laws in quantum
mechanics don't tell you where things
will be based on where they were
yesterday it tells you the probability
of where they will be tomorrow based on
where they were yesterday and some think
that well that slackening of the
deterministic reigns allows freewill to
come in and grab hold and steer the
cosmological unfolding or at least the
human-level unfolding within the
cosmological unfolding and I think that
based on what we know today is not
correct because even if you've got
probabilities governing how things
unfold that's not what we mean by free
will free will is your ability or my
ability to be the ultimate originator of
decisions thoughts actions and if those
decisions thoughts and actions are
ultimately controlled by probabilities
someone in an essence flipping a coin
well that kind of random unfolding is
not what we mean by volitional well
volitional control so I don't think the
probabilities of quantum mechanics even
though they loosen the Newtonian
determinism they do not allow for free
will to enter back into the story so the
way I say it is
it doesn't matter what the laws of
physics are classical quantum I kind of
don't care what they are for this
question if the universe does progress
via a lawful progression that is
determined by laws whatever those laws
might be if those laws are impersonal if
they don't involve the human will or
human psyche as intrinsically part of
those laws then there's no place for
human will to get in on the action
because the laws whatever they may be
determine how things unfold and that's
it max
that to me is the end of a certain kind
of free will I don't think it's the end
of free will totally though but if you
want to know more about that you're
gonna have to ask me that's a separate
question all right what do we got here
um buh buh buh buh buh - got here um
what were the precipices shawl and shawl
Indra Kumar what were the problems
physicists were struggling to combine
gravity and quantum mechanics together
what what's what why is it so hard is
what shal Indra is asking to put gravity
and quantum mechanics together and the
answer is that gravity and quantum
mechanics as formulated by the general
theory of relativity and the
probabilistic laws of the quantum realm
they rely on radically different views
of reality in the Einsteinian
description of gravity gravity is
described by warps and curves in the
space-time geometry and that geometry is
sort of nice and gently curving and
you've seen the imagery the Sun warps
the fabric of space and the earth kind
of rolls around that indentation that's
Einstein's image quantum mechanics has a
completely different image of the
fundamental nature of the world you've
got the uncertainty principle which
tells us that there qualities of the
world better fundamentally uncertain
which means that they fundamentally
fluctuate they chaotically meander among
a whole realm of possibilities
consistent with our limited knowledge
that is imposed by the uncertainty
principle and that chaotic world is
completely at odds would be
gently curving world of the Einsteinian
geometrical approach to gravity so
concretely if you were to examine a
region of space put it right in front of
my face right here a reason of space
right here you were to zoom in on it and
look on fantastically small scales
according to quantum mechanics that
region of space would not be gently
curving it would be widely undulating
fluctuating sort of like the surface of
a violently boiling pot of water and
that chaotic version of space is
incompatible with the smooth image of
space on which Einstein bases his theory
of gravity and so we've been struggling
to blend these two pictures for decades
and at least on paper we believe that
string theory may be the theory that
blends them together but as I said
before we don't yet have observational
or experimental evidence that supports
that conclusion and therefore the best
we can say is that on paper we've got a
theory that seems to work we don't know
if that on paper mathematical theory is
relevant to the real world
relevant to reality mr. X asks is space
like a souffle it depends on what kind
of souffle you have in mind mr. X but I
think I understand what you have in mind
a souffle is you know a structure that
has all sorts of holes in it all sorts
of bifurcating qualities within it and
and it could be then the fundamental
length scales that space might have that
kind of quality and that the smooth
space that we know about in everyday
life may be an approximate average
version space that becomes relevant on
large scales but may not accurately
describe how things look on small scales
and maybe a souffle is a is a good way
of thinking about that what do we have
here okay hello professor
Brian sir oh this is pre on Eshoo we no
photons of energy and momentum but how
can that be
if they are massless yeah right so
you can say you know e equals mc-squared
if M is equal to zero then e is equal to
zero done right so any massless particle
can't have any energy but if you looked
at the first video that we did in this
series I hate to refer back to things
that maybe you haven't seen but what I
really mean is go back and look at the
first video called equals MC squared and
then also look at another video oh
goodness gracious I can't remember which
one it was off the top of my head but
there's another video which I talked
about modifications to equals MC squared
when particles are massless because the
derivation or at least the explanation
that most of us give for equals MC
squared
the rest mass of a particle must be
nonzero for that discussion to go
through in the circumstance when you're
allowing particles to have zero rest
mass equals MC squared takes on a
different form I'll tell you what it is
it's a squared equals P squared C
squared plus M naught squared C to the
fourth where M naught is the rest mass
and if M naught is equal to zero as it
is for a photon you still have a squared
equals P squared C squared or a equals P
times C so for a mass's particle we
learned that the energy and the momentum
stand in a particular relationship
equals P times C but it can be nonzero
and P couldn't be nonzero the momentum
of a particle can be nonzero even if it
is massless so even when a photon slams
into something it can exert a little
force by the change in its momentum FD
equals DP DT after all if you I'm going
to speak a little bit math language and
indeed the idea that a photon has
momentum is experimentally true it's
mathematically true even though a photon
is believed to have zero rest mass okay
what else do we have here lyla asks is
time conscious or do we give time a
consciousness I will interpret that to
mean is turn a fundamental part of
reality or is time something that we
conscious beings impose on the
external world in order to make sense of
experience and I have to say Lila I
don't know I really don't know the
answer to that question I wish I did
know the answer to that question I can
maybe use one of my lifelines right now
I'm gonna poll the audience how many of
you think that time is fundamentally
stitched into the workings of reality
and how many of you think that time is
something that conscious beings like
ourselves impose on the external world I
can argue both ways right as a physicist
I see time intricately interwoven with
every explanation that we give for how
physical processes unfold in fact the
very word unfold assumes that there is a
kind of temporal quality that allows
that unfolding to take place on the
other hand I can imagine it's tough but
I can imagine that time is a concept of
our own making and maybe we could think
about the world in a more on Stinney and
block universe approach where you think
of all of space and all of time just
existing there isn't any unfolding all
events are just out there in a big
frozen river of time the river of time
doesn't flow it's frozen and every event
just exists at a given moment at a given
location and it's only we conscious
beings who are within that frozen river
we somehow have this ability to connect
different events and in that way I'm
bond bout to sneeze scuse me oh gosh
it's never happened to me in this sort
of circumstance before maybe it's a
connection between that and and the
frozen river that I was referring to but
if the frozen river picture true maybe
it's just conscious beings within that
frozen river invent an ocean of time in
order to organize the various events
into a coherent account I don't know I
don't know the answer to that question
okay what do we have here
Andre asks can an electron exist in
multiple locations at the same time and
look Andre we often use that loose
language and talking about quantum
mechanics right we often say that the
weirdness of quantum mechanics is that
an electron says a 30% chance of being
here and a 70% chance of being there and
what that sort of means is we say it's
like it's at both positions at the same
moment in time and only when you measure
observe it you find it here or there
it's loose language it's loose language
because what we really mean is before
the electrons position is measured it
doesn't have a position it's not that
it's located at two places it's that the
very conception of location doesn't
apply until that measurement is
undertaken so roughly you can say yeah
it's kind of smeared out it's hovering
in both locations simultaneously but
location in physics is really something
that is gleaned through observation and
until the observation is made the
weirdness is that you cannot ascribe a
location to the electron
you can only ascribe a probabilistic
distribution of possible locations and
that's very different from having a
position from having a location BH 20/20
asks are atoms conscious I don't know
do you think my gut reaction is no
they're not conscious my gut feeling is
that consciousness is something that
emerges when a lot of atoms come
together into a particular organized
structure like a human brain and within
that organization the particles can
undertake processes undertake
information processing that we
experience as conscious awareness but
there are some really intelligent smart
people who have come to the conclusion
that maybe atoms and particles are
conscious the reason they come to this
conclusion is they said to themselves
look how can thoughtless mindless
sensationalist particles somehow come
together in a group to yield sensations
and reflections and thoughts and
emotions how can ingredients that I
don't have any of those qualities
generate those qualities simply by
coming together in a large group and so
some say they can't do that
the only way that you can have
consciousness is if the ingredients
themselves have some small amount of
consciousness proto consciousness and
only by pooling the proto conscious
qualities can you yield the conscious
experience that you experience in our
experience all the time I don't buy it I
don't buy it yet I get the motivation
but I think it's investing consciousness
with too much mystery I think one day
will understand conscious awareness and
we'll look back at these theories and
understand why people put them forward
but kind of smile and say wow they
really thought consciousness was far
more mysterious than it actually is the
first time we build an artificially
intelligent being who really convinces
us which is tough but really convinces
us that it has internal conscious
self-awareness I think at that point
we'll say yeah it's just a quality of
the world that emerges from organized
motion of particles okay let's see let's
see we got here boy I'm sorry
I need the writing on the screen has
become so small I just wish I could find
a paraglider here we go so I can
actually read this one okay
all right can you speak to whether there
is an edge or a boundary to the universe
could an infinite universe have an edge
well if the universe is infinite we
typically imagine that it doesn't have
an edge just goes on forever and that's
all there is to it but you know that's a
strange idea if you really sit down and
think about a universe where space goes
on forever
it's kind of a breathtaking idea but
it's such an odd and strange idea
because we don't encounter infinitely
big things in everyday life and
therefore we don't really have a deep
intuition for it it would be much easier
to picture the universe if it was finite
in extent and that could mean that it
has an edge an end then you say to me
okay but what's beyond the edge and I'd
say nothing and you'd say well nothing
like empty space and I'd be no nothing
truly nothing not emptiness truly there
is no conception of a location beyond
the edge that's a strange idea too
because anything in the real world you
know if it has an edge certainly there's
a conception of going beyond that edge
so it really strains our intuition to
picture that version of a finite
universe but that's possible too
another possibility is that the universe
has kind of a circular shape to it right
so imagine that the universe is either a
large circle or a big ball right then if
the surface is the universe then again
there's no edge there's no thing that
you run into which is the end of the
universe but yet if you keep walking you
circle around and around and right now
you could say well what's off the
surface of the ball again I'd say wrong
question there is nothing off the
surface of the ball I'm talking about a
three-dimensional surface so it's a lot
harder to picture but it would mean that
that would be the totality of reality so
the finite version is like a little
easier to picture but clearly has its
own strange qualities the infinite
version is pretty perplexing to think
about too and as of today we don't know
which
shape of space is the right one okay
what do we have here
how should we understand the idea this
is coming from Murray thought to rova
how should we understand the idea that
our world is just a hologram mirroring a
really a reality happening near a black
hole good so this is this idea of the
holographic universe the holographic
principle that scientists have been
developing over the course of the last
couple of decades really and it suggests
the following strange picture it
suggests that this three-dimensional
world that you and I inhabit may itself
be the reflection of laws and processes
taking place on a dis ting distant
bounding surface maybe it's at the edge
of the observable universe a thin
distant bounding surface which is able
to fully articulate and describe
everything that happens in this
three-dimensional world that we
experience now why hologram well you may
be familiar that a hologram what is it
it's a thin piece of plastic which when
illuminated correctly yields a realistic
three-dimensional image so it's a
two-dimensional thin plastic yielding a
realistic 3-dimensional image in this
holographic universe scheme you have a
two-dimensional surface not a piece of
plastic but you have a two-dimensional
surface which in essence is illuminated
by the laws of physics yielding as the
theory goes this realistic
three-dimensional world that we inhabit
even though there is another description
an equivalent description that's flat
two-dimensional and far away this idea
does come from black holes which is what
murray notes it really comes from the
understanding of what happens to an
object when it falls inside of a black
hole and the notion that people like
gerardo tuft and many Susskind and many
others have put forward
is that when an object falls through the
surface the event horizon of a black
hole the object kind of leaves an
imprint on the surface a kind of
holographic imprint because the object
itself does fall in in least the
conventional version of the story it's
been developed in other ways that would
take us far afield for me to address
right now but imagine that like the
object does fall in my wallet francis
falls into the black hole but it leaves
a kind of shadow on the surface and that
shadow has all the information contained
in the object and principally you could
extract that information and rebuild the
object from it so you'd have a
three-dimensional object that fell in
described on a two-dimensional surface
by information imprinted on it when the
object fell through that surface and
that's like a hologram and then the
realization is that is a black hole idea
but maybe that idea can apply to the
universe as a whole
with us being the objects that are on
the inside
three-dimensional versions of us being
fully described by two-dimensional
version on a distant surface that
surround us the holographic surface okay
Dylan asks if space is expanding faster
than light how does light reach us and
you're right Einstein told us that
nothing can move through space faster
than the speed of light but his theory
does not in any way constrain the rate
at which space itself expands it can
expand at a rate properly defined that
is greater than the speed of light and
if an object is moving away from us at
faster than the speed of light because
space is swelling so quickly then the
light it emits will not be able to reach
us and indeed the current accelerated
expansion of this bit of space around us
suggests that in roughly a hundred
billion or a trillion years distant
galaxies that we can currently see will
be rushing away from us faster than the
speed of light and therefore the light
that they emit will not be able to cross
the ever widening gap between us and we
will lose the ability to see those
distant galaxies
which means in the far future and when
we look out into deep space we might see
nothing but darkness and we might
therefore be led to conclude that the
universe is unchanging it's static right
it's the distant galaxies their motion
that clued us in that the universe is
expanding we saw those galaxies rushing
away but if in the far future we can't
see those distant galaxies because
they're moving away so quickly now from
the speed of light our descendants may
be lulled into thinking that they live
in a static unchanging universe even
though that's a picture of the world
that we know to be false so it's kind of
a strange state of affairs
yosh pi asks what will happen after the
big rip I don't know after the big rip
laughter sort of molecules and atoms are
torn apart by this possibility only a
possibility that the accelerated
expansion of space is speeding up but
the dark energy is grain gaining in its
force everything will be torn asunder
could things begin again quantum
mechanically basically anything not
forbidden by the quantum laws that has a
nonzero chance of occurring can occur if
you wait long enough and therefore at
least it's possible if the universe kind
of restarts again but now we're in truly
hypothetical and speculative room and I
don't know how to go much further than
that okay what else do we have here
Brian can you comment this is Martin can
you comment on the frozen river
deterministic universe versus quantum
uncertainty does this discrepant mean
that something of our understanding of
time is wrong
so so Martin you're absolutely right
when we talk about the frozen river
picture of the universe were typically
thinking about it in a more classical
sense for imagining even using
Einstein's general to it it's a
classical theory where particles move
along trajectories and objects have
different locations at definite moments
in time and so forth how would that
picture change in the quantum mechanical
version well in a way it doesn't need to
change that much at all now however
rather than talking about particle
positions and velocities you talk about
quantum mechanical wave function and so
you can imagine that that wave function
carries on it develops via the
Schrodinger equation whereas particle
velocities and positions those things
are governed by the Newtonian mechanics
of classical mechanics so in quantum
mechanics you just have a different
equation and a different ingredient the
wavefunction but you can imagine it's
deterministic evolution simply replacing
the deterministic evolution of positions
over time and in that way you can still
have a block universe the the issue that
I'm struggling to fully answer is we
don't have a full answer to the quantum
measurement problem so I'm putting the
quantum measurement problem to the side
imagining Schrodinger's equation is all
that there is and then you could imagine
that just as in the laplacian sense if I
know the positions and velocity of
particles today I can predict them in
the future and in the past if I know the
wavefunction today I can use
Schrodinger's equation to predict it in
the future in the past too and that way
I can invoke that block universe picture
even in the quantum mechanical setting
okay what ifs we have here what's the
best way yaahh ganache has to learn the
math for string theory I would probably
send you to the
to the book by Barton zwieback an
introduction to string theory to sort of
get the lay of the land and then you
basically need to really study
differential geometry and topology and
an algebraic topology and algebraic
geometry there's a lot of math that you
can study if this field sort of grabs
hold of your passion and excitement and
it's a mathematical direction in which
you want to go mmm dr. Brian Greene can
you please explain the relation of laws
of what reading that question and it
scrolled by too fast can I get it back
yeah it was a good one
ah Derek says you touched on the theory
of space being infinite if it has if it
is symfon it has it always been so and
the answer is yeah his face truly is
infinite it was infinite all the way
through right because you know if you go
further back in time when the universe
was half as big is today which is
meaning that galaxies are half the
distance apart than they are today then
the extent was infinite you cut it in
half and half of infinity is still
infinity and you just have that all the
way back to the beginning so the picture
you should have in mind for the origin
of the universe is not the little dot
that many of us use just because it's
easier to visualize think about the
origin of the universe at time 0 is
being infinitely big it's also
infinitely dense so these are the
singularities that come in at the Big
Bang that ultimately we need to really
understand we don't fully yet but
imagine that space is infinitely big and
employee dense and the whole thing
expands and our part of that cosmic
expansion is emanating for one little
point if you will on the initial
infinite surface but there are other
points and those other points a part of
reality and they contribute to the full
extent of space which would be infinite
at the beginning infinite in the middle
and infinite at the end whatever n
actually means ok do we still have time
oh we have a couple more minutes as I am
starting to uh tire out myself but I'd
like to give you the full hour why not
good Brian Greene asking quantum s as
does quantum deacon
parents saw the quantum measurement
problem answer no it does not so quantum
decoherence is a very important part of
quantum mechanics in which when a
quantum mechanical system has sufficient
interactions with its environment its
fundamental quantum mechanical
properties gets suppressed and its
behavior becomes ever closer to the
classical behavior that we know about
from Isaac Newton classical mechanics
but simply suppressing the quantum
features does not make them go away
they're just less visible so all of the
weirdness and strangeness of quantum
mechanics that we are aware of without
thinking about decoherence is still
there even when we think about P
coherence it's just highly suppressed so
a decoherence does is it tends to cause
the wave description of a physical
system to break up into parts that each
look classical but for instance the
quantum measurement says which one of
those classical like outcomes is the
real one that we measure you still have
to pick one and without a solution to
the quantum measurement problem you're
still faced with exactly the same puzzle
of how to go from the realm of
possibilities to the distinct singular
reality that we witness it helps the
quantum measurement problem in certain
ways because we now at least understand
how classical behavior naturally emerges
from the quantum mechanical description
but it's not the fully classical
behavior is there still a menu of
outcomes not a single outcome that
emerges from decoherence okay what else
have we got here
so do I believe in God I'm asked by
juvik Mangal and um yeah I mean it's a
perfectly fine question do I believe in
God well I would put it this way I don't
know whether God exists I'm fully aware
of the fact that a divine being that
wanted to fully stay behind the scenes
and say create this magnificent
universe but not allow us to directly
become aware of the presence of that
divine being that divine being would be
able to accomplish that right if you can
create a universe you can certainly stop
these little puny human brains from
being able to approve your existence so
it's possible that there's a divine will
behind it all it's also possible if
there's not a divine will behind it all
the interesting thing from my
perspective as a physicist is this
question has hardly in any impact on
what I do right I try to figure out
formula equations that will give us
deeper insight into the workings of
reality and whether those equations were
put in place by a divine being or
whether they simply are there by virtue
of how reality is somehow constructed
doesn't really matter I'm still trying
to figure stuff out and I'm thrilled to
work out God's handiwork if that's the
reality and I'm thrilled to work out the
fundamental equations if that's all
there is to now that's speaking as a
physicist speaking as a human being yeah
I would be pretty happy if there if
there was more to reality and divine
being out there that would be you know
an eye-opening stunning profound
realization that I think every member of
the species would find deeply impactful
all the same if there's not a divine
being I think there is a perfectly
viable path to having purpose and
meaning what is that path we have to
recognize that it is astonishing that
we're here it is a stunning fact that we
are able to engage